gomez - period
welcome to maría de marte we're gonna
play other team oh whoa cool this game
has the highest rating I have ever seen
on gamejolt 4.9 Jesus Christ this game
better blow my mind literally all right
here we go
when people say you shouldn't be afraid
of Deaconess delay Helen wants you but
your net did you tomorrow they will fix
day it I am so scared of you press P to
save done amazing what didn't what just
happen it crashed tomorrow day we out of
the bay I could throw to play yeah yeah
okay I start off here I don't know why
but apparently my guy was like yeah it's
time to move now
Timo and I where is the team only excuse
me I am looking for the Timo worry me
I'm alright well we are Mia morning
tomorrow what are you doing you cray
cray don't tell me he's cray cray
oh thank God I have the flashlight
flashlight I don't know what you thought
I just said II to open tomorrow me amore
come over beanie okay alright we have a
key which means it's gonna be a behind
me when I turn around isn't me oh well
well played tomorrow
well played thought I know got it
yeah God bloody was that could only mean
one thing that time a month for tomorrow
miyamoto that doesn't mean we can't have
love so where does this key go I just
got a key to a random place which I
don't know way and I don't know why give
me just a piece what was that
tomorrow day you are not to mayhem on
anymore there
what the [ __ ] would you who the [ __ ] are
you then who do you tomorrow
you look like you were made in paint man
I make you keep looking at me like this
is great
Timon hey what the [ __ ] are you doing
best horror game ever
whoa the game chime Mets lift daddy my
ladder
no ladder hello hello hello what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ]
just jumps carrot in that my nipples are
diamonds right now I say that a lot but
I could cut these off and sell them on
eBay I just need to figure out how to
cut him off and how to replace them
maybe some I heard Vietnamese nipples
are pretty cheap so I might get into
that but that's another thing Oh
tomorrow thank you for thank you muddied
Victor bah fine and if it feels play
date says see more a goddamn you
tomorrow you are insane in the baby oh
my god what was that
well as I was saying earlier can we just
take a moment and appreciate how the
sound of my feet I'm walking like this
oh this is cherry
I've been waiting for you here just why
me why did what did I do
I think it's time for you to die pears
but what I'm always so nice to you what
are you talking about you you're crazy
anyways hey piers I I don't even know
that guy's drunk
um tie late' are in storage room I guess
I'll take a poop hello there's no toilet
in the toilet don't turn who's knocking
on my toilet bathroom hello
now that one toilet hello
all right ma'am Matteo get it number two
who is that ah Mary Poppins
oh I died Oh God
what is this [ __ ] I forgot I could save
some of my batch I have to replay Oh
Timo today we are back in the toilets
tomorrow
very good tomorrow let's not open that
toilet oh my god is stripping even from
the crane shut your mouth I'm not gonna
fall for that you silly goose
are you even a goose in real life I bet
I've been catfished yes what Dodger who
put a toilet in a toilet no wait who put
it whatever someone made it exploding I
don't team my team already miyamura
there you go sorry don't cry for me oh
that's a nice texture that's great great
stuff let's do a little save there I'm
gonna abuse the save feature hi
if I can't save my I don't know I was
gonna sing a song but then I was like
hey tomorrow hey you're the one high
five yeah that's a good I wish I knew
where the key would go tomorrow do you
know where the key oh it's going on
sorry I'll stop oh you can see that the
toilet is going through the wall that's
that's quality hey cherry how you doing
that's great what and my it's been it's
been great having oh hello yeah you got
a little bit of that was that my sky was
my iPad I'm sorry
[ __ ] happens with over is two more
tomorrow Tamura me amore
Tamura me amore jhamora me i'm holy [ __ ]
I found the door I am a genius
thank you very much let's save there's
nothing here
what the [ __ ] why would you waste my
time with rooms like this don't [ __ ] me
tomorrow I will [ __ ] you actually I
won't
I don't date are gay people okay I might
reconsider might reconsider
calm down might reconsider all right all
right we cool all right well I suppose I
could just try all the doors Oh
minecraft let's do a little save cuz you
know out ah what was that the door went
through me that's the scariest thing
ever happened in my entire history of
life I don't think that's how you say it
but who knows these days tomorrow
tomorrow you're playing tricks on me
Tamura Tamura Tamura me shut up
what is this I can't even pick it up
what's the point
it's an eye whoa whoa whoa whoa
alright Jesus Christ they love dumps
games in this game I'm alive it's a
miracle it's a miracle oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but there has to be a key
I mean oh said II to open oh it's a it's
a it's a locker room key oh it just say
which kid
tomorrow mmm I don't creep up on me like
that you're scaring me guys alright I'll
be going now Mia what the [ __ ] writing
my ass oh my god it came all of nothing
okay locker room huh
men Newt Newt order its de Bock our
swing defense mm no that's the labyrinth
locker room hmm I don't know what that
is like I think we should do another
save me I'm all ah yeah I shall go in
here then thank you
I just went here god damn you make me
walk a lot amore wonder how many times I
said tomorrow this video probably more
than two or toward I try and try okay I
don't know who did that I don't care I
just want to go home and suck on
timorous ass oh yeah this is great I'm
sure I won't die at all alright what do
we get oh [ __ ] I can open all of them
literally I bet you Maura miyamura is
hiding in one of the lockers but how
will I know which a locker he's in
hiding in huh this is a very crazy game
I must say yeah Devorah
be amoral Gomorrah miyamura Gomorrah
game over game over game order demo
order me a mole oh there's something
over there no I'm not gonna fall for
your silly tricks again am I but it's so
tempting okay okay don't ever do that
again I'm older I'm older
it's very quiet
oh oh oh stop it stop it
oh god it's one of the fake ones oh no
it's real
it's red ah tomorrow what are you doing
Jade says then I tell you not to creep
up on me
god I thought we had a that way out I
think knowing with ice cream and nips
goddamn see now I didn't see wet wish
key that was for god dammit uh
oh now no now stop it now stop it I fell
for that trick once I'm not gonna fall
for it twice
alright it's not happening look at this
[ __ ] I love your butt cheeks what wait
tomorrow where did I come from Maury
this is where Dora
seriously oh my god I think I peed a
little bit tomorrow
not not Colora tomorrow oh it's right
there oh thank you man we've been in the
toilet so we don't have to return here
that's great thank you thank you
I'm already me I'm already met son Danny
cute gender by a hell of a day
oh my god I'm gonna get a heart attack
playing this [ __ ] [ __ ] jesus [ __ ]
christ a jump-scare all right so this
has to be the maze then I don't want to
be amazing the maze if you know what I'm
sayin hey shits forgot about you man the
labyrinth the labyrinth wait demo day we
are in labyrinth I better save Oh God
all right we can do this
jumpscares are gonna be thicker and then
butter on butter all right so Oh God
that's you do not have to do that you
just did not have to do it it's not much
of a maze so far um come on
Oh shoosh
oh the game continues excelencia why did
it become quiet just because I started
saying we all got this is the end isn't
it okay Jesus Christ
ah okay that's cool then all timotei I
want to get out of this [ __ ] place oh
my god
what did you do huh rush rush rush yeah
no more no more no more to me now stop
it please stop it stop it shoosh I don't
want to I am a team
by Teemo Teemo Tito Marty [ __ ] my way
the [ __ ] am i I don't know
an email my hoe and the show how a bunch
of money tiara
y'all pallidum ear yeah okay that is a
good that was great well your good times
[ __ ] me get like thank you and yeah
brofist thank you very much